c'est qu'il professeur tournesol ce bon
soir 26 ans moi c'est pierre antoine
pour l'édition neige bonjour bonsoir je
m'appelle rémy j'ai 50 ans et deux mois
comme en 50 ans c'est tout con que ce
soir on doit leur parler d'agriculture
numérique digital parce que les
agriculteurs sont en train de vivre une
révolution technologique intense alors
pour les accompagner j'écris une start
up qui permet un agriculteur de vendre
en ligne un câble en blé une première
que l'innovation ça me connaît mais toi
tourner ce qu'est ce que tu vas nous
dire ouais 10 dont j'avais un ordinateur
tu étais pas mais j'ai ma première
connexion internet
je devais être au cp je les fais avec un
modem rtc en 14.4 alors s'il te plaît ne
me dise pas mon expérience moi je suis
un cultivateur beauceron un cultivateur
reposeront ça veut dire quoi
pourquoi pas comme tous les autres
agriculteurs
si tu veux paysans fermiers et cul
terreux et pourquoi pas exploitants
agricoles pour nous tuer non non je suis
un cultivateur beauceron parce que je
cultive des plantes en bosse comme un
éleveur élèvent des animaux qu un
ostréiculteur élève ses huîtres un
maraîcher produit des légumes un
acériculteur beauceron un ancien et
culteurs beauceron des récoltes du sirop
d'érable et oui au québec aussi une
bourse les connaissais pas et moi nous
tiens quand tu l'appellerait toile à
l'agriculteur qui doit relever tous les
défis et les enjeux du
unième siècle ce soir en basse et lui
trouver un nom car c'est clair les
agriculteurs ils font face à un nouveau
défi
nourrir l'humanité quelque chose
d'énorme
et en plus de ça dans leur demande de le
faire bien en alliant environnement et
économie
nourrir l'humanité c'est le titre du
livre de bruno parmentier l'ex directeur
de l'école supérieure d'agriculture
d'angers très j'étais là bas
et quand on arrive là bas il nous dit
juste sûr que vous a pris pour des
décors quand vous avez dit vous vouliez
devenir agriculteur mais en fait vous
allez vers le métier le plus excitant
clairement un agriculteur en plus de
produire il est comptable
les techniciens les mécaniciens souvent
très impliqué dans la vie de la commune
c'est un entrepreneur hors pair et c'est
clair c'est un métier d'avenir
oui l'agriculture les agriculteurs ont
leur part pour relever tous les enjeux
du 21e siècle en 1970 j'avais 4 ans
on était 3 7 milliards d'habitants sur
la planète et on consommer cinq
milliards de tonnes d'équivalent pétrole
en 2030
je serais peut-être pas la retraite on
va être plus de 8 milliards plus du
double et on consommera 15 milliards de
tonnes d'équivalent pétrole
le triple pendant des milliers d'années
le taux de dioxyde de carbone dans
l'atmosphère était inférieur à 300
parties pour millions cette année
nous avons dépassé les 400 partis pour
millions donc on voit bien que l'enjeu
des plantes du sol c'est aussi de capter
ce carbone et de le redescendre dans le
sol et vu la taille des réparations oui
mais j'ai un autre élément que je
voulais donner à tous c'est que par
exemple blé une céréale capte cette fois
plus de dioxyde de carbone qu'elle en
est mais est deux fois plus qu'une forêt
donc tu vois bien que il ya un enjeu
formidable puisque tout ça va se passer
sur la même petite planète la même
surface cultivable et en france il ya
déjà 9 % qui sont sous bouderont et sous
le béton et oui je te propose un retour
en arrière
l'agriculture a traversé de grande
révolution
une première xviie siècle ça y est
l'agriculture commence à travailler le
sol grâce à la traction animale encore
il organise son travail il crée des
rotations sur ces parcelles et ensuite
deuxième grande révolution agricole 20e
siècle ça y est l'agriculteur monde dans
un tracteur il se mécanise il se
familiarise aussi avec la chimie et la
génétique c'est-à-dire qu'il va utiliser
des produits phytosanitaires des
pesticides et de l'engrais tout ça pour
gagner en rendement alors c'est marrant
parce que les vieux
vous nous dites way tous ces changements
tout ce qu'on a vécu
vous le verrez jamais mais en fait je
crois qu'on est à l'aube d'une troisième
grande révolution agricole
oui l'agriculture a toujours participé
aux révolutions aux révolutions
industrielles au changement nos sociétés
humaines
le digital et numériques ouvrent déjà la
voie vers une agriculture 3.0
cette révolution a déjà commencé un
agriculteur aujourd'hui pour piloter sa
parcelle
il appelle à des capteurs pour mesurer
l'humidité du sol à des drones pour
calculer la biomasse d'une plante est ce
que vous êtes monté dans une cabine de
tracteurs dernièrement c'est incroyable
l'agriculteur n'a plus besoin de toucher
le volant pour produire
clairement tout ça on appelle ça
l'agriculture de précision ça pour
principal objectif économiser de l'eau
de l'énergie cre pas de la main d'oeuvre
des engrais pesticides
en gros c'est réduire l'impact d'une
exploitation sur l'environnement oui
c'est bien mais faut qu'on fasse mieux
dire que toutes ces données que tu as
dans ton notre traiteur il faudrait les
récupérer
il faudrait les mettre dans le cloud
il faudra aussi récupérer toutes les
données qui sont liées au sol sa
profondeur sa capacité à retenir de
l'eau sa fertilité récupérer aussi tous
les données des plantes qui poussent sur
ce sol leur vitesse de croissance leurs
besoins et aussi aggloméré toutes les
données et qui sont liées au climat aux
changements climatiques
tu vois bien que si on récupère toutes
ces données là et qu'on les mix on a une
formidable capacité à utiliser le big
data
déjà sur une surface équivalente à un
terrain de football
voyez ce que ça devienne football en ce
moment eh bien on peut récupérer déjà
plus d'un million de données
mais finalement la nature la
biodiversité s'est déjà plaint
d'interaction entre un monde minéral
végétal et animal et donc on n'a rien
inventé
non et tu me parle de biodiversité
cela me fait penser au colza cette
plante aux fleurs jaunes quand mellila
plein au mois de mai eh bien le produit
de l'huile
un tiers de cette huile va finir dans
votre salade
les deux tiers restants dans le
réservoir de votre voiture en tant que
carburant mais c'est pas tout parce que
70% du miel que vous consommez est issu
de fuir de fleurs de colza clairement
c'est une plante qui répondent aux
enjeux du 21e siècle
pourquoi parce qu'elle produit sur un
même espace de l'énergie de
l'alimentation et de la biodiversité
ouais c'est bien mais on doit faire
mieux parce qu'ils ont fait don colza il
occupe le terrain que neuf mois de
l'année après la récolte
on va attendre trois mois à vendre est
implanté un blé tendre par exemple et
tout cet espace des trois mois on va on
pourrait implanter des plantes qui vont
capter encore du carbone si on met des
légumineuses d'yvon capter la zot de
l'air elle transformée en nitrates pour
la prochaine récolte ça va développer
aussi un couvert pour la faune
le gibier et pourquoi pas faire des
fleurs aussi qu'ils apporteront pollen
et nectar aux pollinisateurs sauvages
mais aussi aux abeilles qui en ont tant
besoin et tu vois toutes ces données
tout se mélange va apporter plein de
choses très bonne finalement on va
réfléchir
le solde est palpitant et oui parce que
la nature en fête
l horreur du vide et on le sent bien dès
que le vide apparaît la nature a horreur
du vide et donc s'il ne plus considérer
le sol comme un vulgaire support mais
comme un lieu vivant et productif alors
là tu me parles d'agronomie
est-ce que c'est rentable est-ce que sur
les structures de demain s'est adapté en
2000 une ferme moyenne une grande
culture ses 66 hectares aujourd'hui 85
hectares mon grand père disait avant
avec un quintal je pourrais m'acheter 4
chemise
aujourd'hui avec quatre quintaux
je peux même pas m'acheter une chemise
même à carreaux
et pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui dans
nos assiettes on a bien plus de taxes
que produits agricoles oui alors là
c'est vrai qu'on est moins bien mais il
faut qu'on fasse mieux évidemment toute
l'économie de partage va aider
l'agriculture à partager ses moyens et à
trouver des économies mais ça va pas
suffire
il faudra produire le maximum sur
lui-même surface pour pouvoir réussir
les enjeux du 21e siècle mois déjà sur
mon exploitation
je nourris l'équivalent en énergie de
3500 personnes
mais on doit évidemment encore faire
mieux
en partageant aussi toutes les
trouvailles que les agriculteurs
découvrons sur leur exploitation pour
générer de la connaissance et le partage
de la connaissance sera aussi un moteur
essentiel à la production agricole
mais ce ne sera pas suffisant il faudra
aussi de la reconnaissance de notre
métier est de notre travail auprès du
consommateur
c'est facile bon le bio et ouais tu sais
bien tout ce qui est bon et bio tu vas
me trouver des gens qui on y re
désherber ta parcelle à la main ouais tu
va produire de la nourriture saine et
sans pesticides
oui alors le bio c'est bien mais faut
qu'on fasse mieux faut qu'on fasse
beaucoup mieux faut qu'on produise plus
il faut que assurer la sécurité
alimentaire produire des choses de
qualité
et puis aussi respecter encore plus son
environnement
ouais je sais pas si c'est vraiment la
solution
tu vois quand on pose la question aux
consommateurs qui se consomme bio qui
vont dans des amap qui parle de
permaculture même qui rêvent d'une
agriculture urbaine on sent bien une
derrière c'est pas forcément le premier
intérêt
le respect de l'environnement ou le
retour à des valeurs et des traditions
ou le même respect de leur santé ce
qu'ils y la vraie question qui pose en
fait c'est timonerie qui est la personne
qui remplit mon assiette est bien là
grâce au numérique
on va aller plus loin parce que avec le
numérique on va réussir à recréer le
lien entre l'agriculteur et le
consommateur
vous verrez demain quand vous allez
aller acheter un paquet de pâtes
vous verrez l'agriculteur en train de se
mettre son blé et vous aurez pris
connaissance de toutes la traçabilité
jusque dans votre assiette
et alors là par rapport à la question
que tu me posais au début de la
conférence
comment j'appellerais un agriculteur qui
va répondre aux enjeux agricoles du 21e
siècle a gelé
c'est un agriculteur
ah oui une agriculture connectés mais
avec beaucoup de data beaucoup
d'agronomie beaucoup de reconnaissance
auprès du consommateur aussi
ouais l'avenir est devant nous comme
disait perdre et perdre ac
l'avenir est devant nous mais on l'aura
dans le dos à chaque fois qu'on fait
demi tour je rêve de m'acheter 4 chemise
pourquoi pas à carreau avec un quintal
oui alors est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
avoir confiance à deux agriculteurs
parce que demain on veut aller plus loin
mais avec vous parce qu'on est bien plus
fort à deux